Die Nerd News Wer erpresst wird, sollte nicht zahlen. Diese Binsenweisheit scheint das FBI jetzt zumindest in bestimmten Fällen zu revidieren. Denn wer sich einen Trojaner einfängt, der die Festplatte verschlüsselt und zur Freigabe der Daten ein Lösegeld fordert, bleibt laut Joseph Bonavolonta vom FBI oft nichts anderes übrig. Zu gut sei die sogenannte Ransomware, wie z.B. Cryptolocker, die meistens über entsprechend präparierte Webseiten oder E-Mail-Anhänge den Weg auf Computer findet. Bonavolonta und seine Kollegen können dabei auf fast 1000 Fälle, die den Behörden binnen 12 Monaten gemeldet wurden, zurückgreifen. Insgesamt wurden die Opfer dabei um 18 Millionen US-Dollar erleichtert. Um ihren Ruf zu wahren, würden die Erpresser die Festplatte in der Tat nach Zahlung des Lösegeldes entschlüsseln. Sicherer und billiger ist aber in jedem Fall ein Backup. Der Kampf um Werbeblocker geht in eine neue Runde. Nachdem Bild.de Browser mit Werbeblockern den Zugang verwehrte, ließen sich die Blockerfirmen nicht lange bitten und entwickelten Gegenmaßnahmen. Darauf hat der Springer Verlag nun reagiert. Der Betreiberfirma von AdBlock Plus hat das Landgericht Hamburg per einstweiliger Verfügung die Verbreitung von Entgehungsregeln verboten. Zusätzlich soll auch jeder abgemahnt werden, der dokumentiert, wie man die AdBlock Blockade loswirkt. Das bekam auch der YouTuber Tobias Richter zu spüren, der auf seinem YouTube-Kanal erklärte, wie einfach sich die Sperre umgehen lässt. Die Anwälte von Bild.de sehen in dieser Anleitung einen Verstoß gegen §95 des Urheberrechtsgesetzes. Dazu müssten die Werbeblocker Blocker aber eine wirksame technische Maßnahme darstellen, was bezweifelt werden darf. Das sieht wohl auch Richter so. Sein Anwalt gab an, dass man weder die geforderte Unterlassungserklärung abgeben, noch die Kosten für die Abmahnung übernehmen werde. Wir drücken die Daumen. Mit exakt 404 Ja-Stimmen hat der Bundestag die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als sogenannte Höchstspeicherfrist wieder eingeführt. Laut Gesetz werden Handy-Standortdaten vier Wochen, Verkehrsdaten wie SMS, Berufnummern und IP-Adresse des Handys sogar zehn Wochen gespeichert. Aus technischen Gründen sind bei SMS auch Inhalte von der Speicherung betroffen. Auch enthält das Gesetz keinerlei Ausnahmeregelung für Berufsgruppen wie Anwälte, Ärzte oder Journalisten, die einem Berufsgeheimnis unterliegen oder Quellenschutz gewähren müssen. Das Gesetz, das mit einem rekordverdächtigen Tempo durch die Instanzen gejagt wurde, schafft außerdem den Straftatbestand der Datenhehlerei. Das könnte für Whistleblower gefährlich werden, die Daten aus ihrem Unternehmen und Behörden an die Öffentlichkeit bringen und Journalisten über diese Daten berichten wollen. Der Verein Digitalcourage und andere haben Klage gegen die neue Auflage der Vorratsdatenspeicherung angekündigt. Auch das EU-Parlament hat im Internet einen Bärendienst erwiesen. Mit dem nun beschlossenen sogenannten Trilogkompromiss zur Netzneutralität steht es den Telekommunikationsunternehmen frei, gewisse Dienste als Spezialdienste zu markieren, die sie auf die Überholspur schicken dürfen. Das hat die Telekom in ihrem Blog dankend aufgenommen. Dort fasst Konzernchef Höttges den Begriff Spezialdienst so weit, dass fast jeder heutige Internetdienst darunter fällt. Walter behauptet eher, dass Spezialdienst die Lösung für Start-ups sei, um Nachteile gegenüber Firmen wie Google, die weltweit Serverpacks besäßen, auszugleichen. Darüber, wie gut das für Google funktioniert, können Telekom Kunden ein Lied singen, während sie auf ihre YouTube Videos warten.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 217, live aus der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin im Chaos Computer Club Berlin mit Linus, Frank, Sebas und TAS. Hallo und guten Abend.
Und wir waren gerade live dabei, Markus tolle Premiere-Podcast abzueanalysieren, um euch zu erklären, wie das eigentlich mit den Marken funktioniert. Das werden wir jetzt mal weitermachen.
Warte, gleich. Ich möchte vorher noch kurz sozusagen, ich möchte noch kurz eine News-Beeldung, die in der Nerd-News auch gerade drin war, aufgreifen. Und zwar, ich hab ja gerade einen schönen Tweet gelesen, die Telekom reagiert mal schnell, dass ich das noch erleben darf. Die haben ja tatsächlich sozusagen einen Tag, nachdem das EU-Parlament gesagt hat, ja, so ein Netzteil da tritt, ist super, wir definieren das mal auf eine Art und Weise, die die aushebelt, gesagt, ja, wir möchten gerne, wie war das, Start-ups?
Sie wollen einfach nur ein paar Prozent von dem schönen Start-up-Umsatz abfangen.
Also was mich daran total fasziniert ist, früher war es ja immer so, die Internet-Anbieter haben gesagt, naja, also die großen Anbieter, die machen uns ja die Leitungen so dick. Wir möchten, dass die sich an unserer Infrastruktur beteiligen. Und das finde ich jetzt so perfide, dass sie sagen, naja, die großen Anbieter haben ihre Server eh in der Nähe. Das können die Kleinen sicher nicht leisten. Dann möchten wir von denen ein paar Prozent, um sie durchzuleiten.
Schönes Start-up haben sie da.
Als fairen Beitrag für die Nutzung der Infrastruktur.
Bei einem von InfoX-Providern in Deutschland musst du ein paar Prozent von deinem Umsatz lassen. Es gibt ja noch den Rest Europas, es gibt noch den Rest der Welt. Und dann gibt es auch noch ein kleines bisschen Restumsatz für dich.
Das ist so perfide und schamlos vor allem.
Ja, das ist schamlos. So sind sie.
Also ich würde mal vermuten, dass sie damit einigermaßen Schiffbruch erleiden. Weil natürlich wird es ein paar Firmen geben, die sich da halt erpressen lassen müssen, weil ihr Geschäftsmodell halt so aussieht. Aber ich erwarte eigentlich eher, dass der Trend dahingeht, dass so eine Firma wie Netflix oder so, die halt irgendwie darauf angewiesen sind, dass ihre Videos ruckelfrei kommen, halt ja das Schutzgeld zahlen und andere halt einfach sich Businesses suchen werden und da Kreativität hin tun werden, wo sie halt keinen breiten Schutzgeld zahlen müssen.
Also was ich mir vorstelle, ich würde ja als User hingehen und sagen, ich möchte bitte bei einem ISP sein, der das nicht macht. Meint ihr, dass das auch als Verkaufskontakt kommen wird?
Also ich meine, wenn du kannst, klar. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich ein, also alle anderen großen ISPs, also nicht alle, aber fast alle anderen großen ISPs sagen ja, wir peeren halt, das heißt, wir schließen uns halt zusammen, wie es in der Tat mal gemeint war. Und nur die Telekom sagt halt, wir sind so groß, wir haben so viele Kunden. Wenn du unsere Kunden schnell erreichen möchtest, musst du Geld dafür bezahlen, dass du dich auch schnell anbinden kannst. Wenn sie sowas mit Google machen, na gut, da kann man drüber reden, oder mit Netflix oder so, das kann man zumindest so inhaltlich nachvollziehen. Aber wenn sie es halt mit so kleinen Audio-Streaming-Startups machen, würde ich sagen, könnte das Kartellamter schon durchaus noch mal ein Wortchen mitzureden haben.
Wäre es nicht gut, wenn sowas wie die Telekom staatliche Infrastruktur wäre?
Also ja klar, ich meine, es ist vollkommen logisch, dass so was wie ein hochbrandbreitiges Netz sollte halt eigentlich eine öffentliche Infrastruktur sein. Also es muss nicht staatlich sein, sondern halt am besten öffentlich. Das heißt, es ist so, dass es halt nicht profitorientiert ist. Und dann, so wie halt im Baltikum, da hat der Staat halt auch einfach Faser in jedes Dorf gelegt und gesagt, alle Firmen, die brandbreiten Dienstanbeit anbieten wollen, können zu den gleichen Konditionen Kapazität auf diesem Netz liegen und damit wird halt dieses Netz ausgebaut. So gehört sich das für natürliches Monopol.
Schön wär's gewesen. Heute machen wir aber bei Chaosradio etwas ganz anderes. Nämlich wir reden über professioneller Hacker. Und haben in der ersten Stunde schon so ein bisschen gelernt, dass da sehr viel theoretische Arbeit auch dabei ist. Und dass man sich auch mit Kundendingen rumschlagen muss. Zum Beispiel sowas wie, naja, das kostet halt schon auch Geld, wenn ihr uns einkauft. Und dann wollen die vielleicht auch das Ergebnis gar nicht so gerne haben. Und es gibt noch die Diskussion, also stellt sozusagen, wenn ich mir jetzt so jemanden angucke, der die Sicherheit meiner Firma oder meines Produktes überprüfen soll, stelle ich dem jetzt mal einen Quellcode zur Verfügung. Das ist der sogenannte Whitebox-Ansatz. Oder sage ich, was sagen die dann immer so? Du bist doch Hacker, zeig mal was du kannst.
Ja, das muss man denen dann am Anfang immer mal kurz erklären, dass man eigentlich da ist, um ihnen zu helfen und nicht, um irgendjemanden bloßzustellen. Aber die Angst ist natürlich am Anfang da.
Das mit dem Bloßstellen ist wirklich ein großes Problem. Viele, die unerfahren sind mit solchen Untersuchungen in den eigenen Firmen, die denken wirklich, dass da jemand an den Pranger gestellt wird für irgendetwas, was passiert.
Also warte mal, ist die Erwartung von den Leuten, die dieses Thema bauen, ist quasi, sie dürfen eigentlich keine Fehler machen. Und es ist nicht verinnerlich, dass es eigentlich der natürliche Gang ist, wenn du eine Software baust, dann hat die auch eine Schwachstelle.
Ich würde das jetzt mal vorsichtig sagen, das ist ja eher ein Problem der Kultur des Unternehmens, wenn die Mitarbeiter irgendwie Probleme befürchten, wenn das Unternehmen ihnen Leute zur Seite stellt, die teuer bezahlt werden, um ihnen zu helfen bei ihrem Produkt. Deswegen ist da so ein Psychologiestudium gar nicht so schlecht, da irgendwie auch zu sehen, wie kriege ich denn die Person jetzt mit an Bord? Wie nehme ich denen auch ihre Sorge? Also es ist mir jetzt wirklich noch nie untergekommen, dass irgendjemand von denen, sind ja dann auch nicht immer nur angestelltes Unternehmen, es sind häufig auch Zulieferer. Dann hast du halt so einen richtig schönen Clusterfuck, weil dann der, was weiß ich, das Unternehmen hat die App jetzt von irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen gekauft und dieses andere Unternehmen sagt dann aber, nee, also in unserem Service-Level-Agreement steht drin, ihr kriegt keinen Einweg in den Source Code oder so, oder ihr dürft das gar nicht prüfen lassen, dann streiten die sich da erst mal. Und das sind halt die dümmsten Zulieferer, weil das Unternehmen an das du verkaufst spendiert dir noch einen Pentest.
Also nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel deine Podcast-App, du hast jetzt einen Studentenbeauftragten, also wir wollen konkret bleiben, du hast da so einen Studentenbeauftragten, der hat dir die geschrieben und dann fällt dir plötzlich ein, weil du halt so Leute wie uns kennst, irgendwie dass du dir ja vielleicht doch mal eine Sicherheitsanalyse machen lassen. Dann gehst du zu deinem Studenten und sagst dem, ich würde ja doch gerne mal an die Sicherheit reingucken lassen. Und dann sagt der Student so, weißt du in der Macke, bei mir ist alles sicher. So und natürlich rücke ich den Sourcecode nicht raus, weil das wäre mein Lebensunterhalt. Und dann sagst du aber, ich würde trotzdem die Sicherheit gerne prüfen lassen. Dann sagt der, mach was du willst, aber nicht mit meinem Sourcecode. Und dann gehst du halt zu Thorsten zum Beispiel und sagst, pass auf, der gibt mir den Sourcecode nicht, kannst du trotzdem mal reingucken. Und dann findet Thorsten da halt irgendwie eine Tonne Zeug drin. Und dann gehst du zurück zu ihm und sagst so, Alter, ey, das ist nur für einen Scheiß hier abgeliefert. So irgendwie, da sind 15 Sicherheitslücken drin. Ich will, dass du die mal fixen, und zwar für lau, weil du hast ja gesagt, bei dir ist alles sicher. Das ist so ein typischer Ablauf eines solchen Einkaufsdialoges. Und unter Involvierung eines Sicherheitslückens.
Aber wie findet Thorsten die 15 Sicherheitslücken?
Da waren wir ja gerade. Also wir nehmen mal halt an, also der gibt dir den Sourcecode nicht, sondern wir müssen es halt Blackbox machen. Dann fängt man halt an, sich die einzelnen Komponenten anzugucken. Also was haben wir denn da so? Also da gibt es halt zum einen ein Payment, also da wo halt irgendwie dein Geld fließt. Da würde man, wenn man jetzt sagt, du hast nur eine Woche am meisten Zeit wahrscheinlich verbringen. Das heißt, wir gucken uns halt an, wie wird, wenn die Kreditkartendaten von deiner App zu deinem Server gebracht, wie wird auf deinem Server die Verbindung zum Kreditkartendienstleister hergestellt? Verwendest du da richtige Verschlüsselungen? Reicherst du die Daten?
Ich würde es aber erst endlich noch eine Runde genauer wissen. Wie machst du das?
Man muss sich dann schon genau angucken, was ist das für eine App, wie kommuniziert die, wo läuft die drauf. Da muss man einfach nur ein paar mehr Hürden nehmen. Wenn irgendwelche Programmierer den Code oder die Apps nicht rausrücken, dann heißt das ja nicht, dass man da nicht rankommt. Man hat einfach ein paar mehr Hürden zu nehmen. Manchmal ist es komplizierter und manchmal nicht. Ich habe tatsächlich gerade genau so einen Fall, wo ein Kunde mich damit beauftragt hat, etwas mit so einer Anwendung zu tun und zu analysieren. Der hat von seinem Drittanbieter noch nicht mal das Package bekommen, was auf den Geräten deploit wird, geschweige denn den Source Code. Dann muss man einfach versuchen, erst mal zu schauen, wie kommuniziert die App. Dann kann man den Netzwerkverkehr analysieren. Daran kann man schon mal eine ganze Menge sehen. Man kann gucken, ob die Krypto sauber ist und so weiter. Dann kann man an anderen Punkten ansetzen, an die Anwendung zu gelangen. Zum Beispiel auf einem Telefon. Da gibt es häufig auch noch andere Vektoren, die man nutzen kann. So ein Android-Telefon kann man dann routen. Dann hast du schon mal Zugriff auf die Daten auf dem Device, was auf dem Dateisystem liegt. Dann kann man da schon mal schauen, was für Daten werden von der Anwendung auf der Festplatte oder auf dem Dateisystem gespeichert. Sind da sensible Daten dabei? Vielleicht sogar Passwörter oder irgendwelche kryptographischen Schlüssel, die dann da abgelegt werden. Dann kann man die nutzen und vielleicht sogar versuchen, einen eigenen Client zu bauen, der dann später mit einem Backend kommuniziert und auch verschlüsselt kommuniziert. Und dann geht man halt so Stück für Stück, arbeitet man sich dann da halt so durch. Das ist teilweise mühsam, teilweise geht es auch ganz schnell. Und auch da geht man ja oft den Weg des geringsten Widerstands. Das heißt so, am erst guckt man sich so äußerlich ein bisschen an, was passiert da. Und zusätzlich eher dann, ja, wenn man eben nichts anderes mehr findet oder so, dann kann man halt immer noch auch die Applikationen zum Beispiel in den Disassembler werfen und sich den Code angucken und versuchen herauszufinden, was die Anwendung am Ende tut, wie Daten von A nach B fließen innerhalb der Anwendung, wo vielleicht irgendwas verschlüsselt wird, ob da irgendwelche logischen Fehler eingebaut sind in der Applikation. Und das ist dann halt so dieser klassische Blackbox-Ansatz. Man muss halt einfach eine Hürde nach der anderen nehmen und das ist einfach mühsam und sehr zeitaufwendig. Und würde ich auch niemandem empfehlen, das so auf die Art und Weise durchzuführen. Weil am Ende wird das halt immer irgendwie einen Weg geben, an irgendwelche Geheimnisse zu gelangen. Und es ist ja jetzt auch kein Geheimnis, dass man eher auf Geheimnisse... Also, dass man auch solche... Man soll halt nicht dafür sorgen, dass der Algorithmus geheim gehalten wird, sondern eben andere Dinge. Das heißt, das Kerkovsche Prinzip wird halt oft genug verletzt und die Programmierer sollten halt einfach davon absehen, diese Denkweise weiterzuführen. Sie sollten eher davon ausgehen, dass grundsätzlich sowieso jeder Zugriff hat auf die Anwendung und vielleicht sogar auf den Source-Code. Das kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass der Arbeitsrechner von dem Programmierer bereits kompromittiert ist und der Source-Code schon in irgendwelchen Foren die Runde macht. Das kann ja halt auch durchaus möglich sein. Und dann ist es eben einfacher für Consultants wie uns einfach schnell mal in diesen Code rein zu gucken und eben sehr viel schneller und gezielter nach den klassischen Programmierfehlern zu suchen.
Aber wenn du diesen Blackbox-Ansatz machst und dann diese Hürden nehmen musst, ist das dann jedes Mal von vorne? Oder gibt es da auch dann irgendwie Werkzeuge dafür? Wie macht man das?
Jaja, da gibt es dann natürlich auch Werkzeuge. Zum einen eben so allgemeine Werkzeuge, die es auf jeder Linux-Distribution gibt und auch sonst wie frei im Internet erhältlich sind. Es gibt ja schon seit sehr langer Zeit solche Linux-Distributionen wie Backtrack oder Kali Linux, die im Grunde auch nur so ein Werkzeugkoffer sind mit Open Source Tools oder irgendwelchen Werkzeugen, die mal von Hackern und Sicherheitsforschern entwickelt wurden, um die Analysearbeiten zu erleichtern. Oder eben auch eigene Werkzeuge, die man dann am Ende vielleicht nicht releast, weil es halt eben einfach Ergebnisse aus jahrelanger Spezialisierung sind, die man halt durchgemacht hat. Also wenn ich jetzt zehn Jahre in der Branche arbeite und mich auf bestimmte Plattformen oder Anwendungen spezialisiert habe, dann habe ich ja im Laufe der Zeit auch Anwendungen oder Programme zur Analyse entwickelt, die ich jetzt nicht jedem Preis gebe, weil das macht ja vielleicht auch irgendwie meinen Wert auf diesem Security-Markt aus, wenn ich eben Werkzeuge habe, die mich sehr viel effizienter arbeiten lassen.
Aber kommt man da nicht auch in eine moralische Zwickmühle? Will man so eine Werkzeuge, also aus der idealistischen Perspektive nicht, dass die möglichst jeder in der Hand hat, damit möglichst jeder möglichst gut testen kann?
Natürlich, aber ich denke da wiegt man halt auch ab. Also es gibt durchaus Werkzeuge und Algorithmen, die man halt releasen sollte, damit alle was davon haben. Aber ich meine jetzt nicht so einzelne Geschichten, so was ich, wenn ich eine Sicherheitslücke in irgendeiner Software finde, die frei verkauft wird oder die irgendwie Open Source ist, dann behalte ich diese Sicherheitslücke nicht für mich und ich werde auch keinen Exploit dafür bauen, also irgendwie ein Stück Programm, was diese Sicherheitslücke ausnutzt und das Ganze für mich behalten. Das sind dann eher Sachen, die man dann veröffentlichen sollte, damit die Hersteller der Software auch ein bisschen unter Druck gesetzt sind, diese Probleme schnell zu beheben, damit eben die anderen, die diese Software nutzen, nicht mehr gefährdet sind.
Wie wichtig ist es in so einem Fall eigentlich, dass ihr Software benutzt, die wiederum andere geschrieben haben? Weil es gibt ja irgendwie so Schad-Baukästen, also z.B. hat jemand gefragt, Metasploit ist wohl einer oder Open-Was? Also das sind ja so Baukäste für Schad-Software.
Also Metasploit finde ich jetzt überhaupt nicht, fällt gar nicht so in die Kategorie.
Kannst du kurz erklären, was das ist, bevor du sagst, warum es nicht in die Kategorie fällt?
Ja, Metasploit würde ich gerade sagen. Das ist eher so ein Framework, wo sich halt irgendwie mal Leute hingesetzt haben und gesagt haben, wir bauen, wir müssen uns immer in dieser ganzen Security-Branche, sind wir halt immer mit diesen gleichen Problemen konfrontiert. Das, was du ja gerade angesprochen hast, wir müssen immer mal irgendwo einen Portscan machen und immer mal gucken, ob irgendwie, weiß ich, eine Krypto-Implementierung korrekt antwortet auf irgendeinem Server und so weiter. Das sind halt so diese ganzen allgemeinen Tests, die kann man ja automatisiert durchführen und dafür kann man halt Scanner bauen. Und dann gibt es halt eben diese Exploits, also um halt irgendwie auch beweisen zu können, dass eine Sicherheitslücke in einer Software ausnutzbar ist, kann man dann halt Exploits bauen. Und irgendwann haben sich mal Leute gesagt, wir müssen das immer wieder machen und immer wieder fangen wir so, haben wir den ganzen Overhead, wie jedes Mal so ein Unit-Test irgendwie neu zu bauen. Wir bauen uns jetzt erstmal ein Framework, sodass man, weiß ich mal, so ein Scanner oder irgendein Analysewerkzeug oder irgendein Exploit einfach schnell prototypen kann und in dieses Framework reinwirft. Und das Ganze ist dann wieder im Grunde genommen ein riesengroßer Werkzeugkoffer, nur halt eben sehr speziell für diese ganze Security-Branche. Und das ist wirklich nur ein Framework. Das ist halt so, wie wenn ich mir ein LKW miete und da Regale einbaue, dass da meine Koffer mit den Werkzeugen perfekt reinpassen, damit ich damit zum Kunden fahren kann. Metasploit ist halt kein Baukasten für irgendeine Schadsoftware, sondern einfach nur ein Framework, was es erleichtert, solche Tests zu implementieren. Und natürlich eben auch Exploit, keine Frage, aber deswegen ist es noch lange kein Schadsoftware-Baukasten.
Also worauf du ja hinaus willst, Markus, ist, dass natürlich viele dieser Werkzeuge, wenn sie für Angriffe auf Computersysteme nutzbar sind, unter anderen Bedingungen sicherlich auch für solche Angriffe genutzt werden können. Und grundsätzlich ist ja erstmal die Frage, wenn ich jetzt dahin komme und ich habe die Aufgabe, ein System oder eine App oder sonst was gegen einen zeitgemäßen Angreifer zu verteidigen, dann kann ich mir jetzt nicht irgendwelche esoterischen, religiösen Fesseln anlegen und sagen, ich mach das aber jetzt immer, ich fange jetzt immer mit einem Stock an und baue mir meinen Hammer selber. Wenn ich weiß, folgender Spezialhammer, Presslufthammer ist auf dem Markt erhältlich. Oder Hammer-Podcast-App. Folgende Tools sind leicht erhältlich, folgende Angriffe gibt es. Dann ist es natürlich auch sinnvoll, diese im Rahmen von Tests durchzuführen, zur Anwendung zu bringen. Es bringt ja nichts zu sagen, ich habe jetzt hier den weißen Westepenntest gemacht ohne Angriffe. Du willst ja Angriffe durchführen, also nutzt du natürlich auch Tools, die Angriffe durchführen können. Zum Zwecke oder mit dem Ziel, diese Angriffe abzuwehren.
Genau. Und es gibt halt wirklich viele Kunden, die eben nicht damit einverstanden sind, wenn man einfach nur ein theoretisches Risiko aufzeigt in einem Stück Software. Manche wollen halt wirklich sehen, dass das auch wirklich kaputt geht. Weil auch gerade in größeren Software-Entwicklungsfirmen, die Entwickler stellen sich auch dann oft quer und denken halt so, man fährt ihnen halt irgendwie gegen Karren und die leugnen dann erstmal, dass man da einen Fehler gemacht hat. Und dann ist es halt einfacher auch, dass man dann einfach da hergehen kann und sagen kann, so pass auf, wenn ich hier diesen Knopf drücke, dann bin ich rot auf dieser Kiste da und das sagt halt alles. Ihr könnt jetzt irgendwie diskutieren, so lange wie ihr wollt. Das ist eigentlich auch egal, wer Schuld daran hat. Die Sache ist, es funktioniert. Hier ist der Beweis. Und wir müssen diese Sache jetzt fixen. Und jetzt lasst uns eher darüber diskutieren, wie man das fixt und nicht darüber diskutieren, wie wir das mit der Schuldzuweisung klären. Also das ist eben so eine Diskussion, die man regelmäßig hat.
Klappt dann trotzdem nicht, aber gegenüber Dritten unbeteiligt machst du einen sehr konstruktiven Eindruck.
Aber zu dem Punkt, nochmal zurückzukommen. Man benutzt auch andere Software sozusagen. Die Software, die man, wenn man böse ist, auch direkt so als Schadding ins einen setzen kann.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Kategorien von Software. Man hat zum einen so etwas wie Exploits oder Trojaner, die man dann auf das Zielsystem aufbringt, um zu seinem Ziel zu kommen. Vorher hat man meistens noch ein bisschen mit Reverse-Engineering zu tun. Also, dass man einfach Software auseinandernimmt, dekompiliert, sie wieder lesbar macht, sie in einen Zustand bringt, wo man sie verstehen kann, um die Fehler daran zu finden. Wenn man den Source Code nicht kriegt, nehme ich mir eine App, dekompiliere sie, mache da lesbaren Code für mich draus, um zu verstehen.
Außer bei Oracle, die haben das verboten.
Insiderwitz. Es gibt Firmen, die sagen, du darfst die Software nicht dekompilieren.
Selbst wenn du einen Security-Test machst?
Selbst wenn du einen Security-Test machst. Eigentlich ist es immer Bullshit, in Deutschland darfst du es tun. Es gibt zwei Gründe, wie du das machen kannst. Zum einen, um Kompatibilität mit dieser Software zu stellen, zum anderen, um sie zu überprüfen. Dann darfst du die Software auseinandernehmen und zerlegen. In der Regel, wenn du so etwas im Auftrag machst, dann lässt du dir dieses Einverständnis geben. Häufig ist es gerade so, wenn große Firmen zum Beispiel irgendwelche Apps analysieren lassen, die sie verwenden wollen, was immer häufiger der Fall ist, dann holen sich das Einverständnis von dem Hersteller diese App und sagen, pass auf, wenn wir da nicht reingucken dürfen oder das nicht analysieren lassen dürfen, dann kaufen wir sie halt nicht.
Aber umgekehrt geht auch. Der große Kunde sagt dem Hersteller, wir wollen hier reingucken und der sagt, so habt ihr eine Meise, wenn ihr das macht, zeige ich euch an. Diese Fälle gibt es auch. Die lassen sich tatsächlich auch unter Druck setzen, weil keiner hat dann Bock auf juristische Auseinandersetzung.
Wir haben hier eine Frage aus dem Publikum.
Wenn es so viele Leute gibt, die sich dagegen stellen, woher kommen dann eigentlich die gesamten Aufträge?
Meistens ist es so, dass es in so einem Unternehmen verschiedene Interessen gibt. Es gibt die Leute, die nicht wollen, dass ihr Unternehmen kleinige Schlagzeilen hat. Die sind dann meistens noch die, die man eher dazu überreden kann oder die eher auf die Idee kommen. Dann gibt es Unternehmen, bei denen es mittlerweile eher normal geworden ist. Die sagen, wenn wir eine neue Applikation releasen, dann müssen wir in den Prozess, bis diese Applikation nach draußen kommt, dass dann jemand unterwegs ist, muss eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung rein. Da gibt es Standards, da kannst du vielleicht am besten was zu sagen, wie das so funktioniert mit der Security Compliance.
Ja genau, da die Unternehmen ganz gerne vorher ein mögliches Risiko eingehen wollen, sagt man ganz einfach, wenn man kritischen Pfad in einem Produkt hat, dass der einfach nochmal durchleuchtet wird, bevor man damit wirklich an die Öffentlichkeit geht oder ein Produkt im Livebetrieb einsetzt. Man versucht dann meistens auf die Bereiche zu beschränken, die wirklich auf einem kritischen Pfad sind und erstmal dieses Thema zu bewerten und dann im Nachgang der restlichen Infrastruktur nachzuziehen.
Die Aufträge, am Ende wollen ja schon alle, dass es sicher ist. Und ich glaube, wir haben auch jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr von den alltäglichen Grabenkämpfen da gesprochen. In der Regel schleift sich das im Laufe des Projektes ein. Also Anfangs sagen alle, oh mein Gott, jetzt kommen hier die Hacker rein und so. Und dann muss man einfach nur am Anfang eben ein bisschen freundlich sein, sich allen gegenüber konstruktiv zeigen, dass man das dann auch in der Regel hinkriegt, dass am Ende doch alle an einem Strang ziehen.
Man arbeitet zu Beginn auch so ein Stück weit als Mediator, um zwischen den Fronten zu verhandeln, dass die Leute sich an einen Tisch setzen und man lösungsorientiert arbeitet und nicht problemorientiert.
Aber der Konflikt, den ich eigentlich heutzutage sehe, ist, dass die Unternehmen nämlich wirklich am Ende dann sich erst die Leute holen. Das heißt, sie machen sich lange genug keine Gedanken darüber. Das heißt, diese sichere Entwicklung oder so ist nicht von Anfang an in der Gestaltung des Produktes oder der Dienstleistung mit drin. Das heißt, sie entscheiden sich vielleicht bewusst oder unbewusst dagegen, von Anfang an die Experten mit an Bord zu haben. Und lassen sich dann am Ende lieber einmal alles kaputt hauen und fixen dann die Probleme und sagen, okay, jetzt ist es reif. Ich persönlich würde eigentlich eher den Unternehmen dazu raten, von vornherein Sicherheitserwägungen schon in der Architektur- und Designphase ausreichend zu berücksichtigen.
Also typischerweise kann man sagen, je größer ein Unternehmen ist, und desto häufiger es schon mal irgendwie tatsächlich sich auf die Fresse gepackt hat, weil sie halt Sicherheitsprobleme zu spät eingegangen haben, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass sie halt einen Prozess haben, wenn sie halt eine neue Applikation einführen und ein neues Produkt oder was auch immer oder überhaupt irgendwie an ihre IT rumfummeln, dass es dann halt da irgendwie schon von vornherein so eine strukturelle Beteiligung der Sicherheitsabteilungen gibt und die dann halt irgendwann sagen, okay, wir holen heute von extern dazu. Je kleiner das Unternehmen ist, je mehr ist halt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, so Start-up-Mode ist, je weniger Erfahrung die Leute auch damit haben, sich halt irgendwie als Prozess zu begreifen, desto eher gibt es da halt große Widerstände bzw. halt Unwillen, halt sowas halt von vornherein zu berücksichtigen. Das ist halt so Daumenregel. Es gibt halt natürlich Abweichungen in beide Richtungen. Es gibt auch große Unternehmen, die sind einfach so stulle. Da fragt man sich, wie sie mal zu groß werden konnten. Es gibt kleine Unternehmen, bei denen ist die Security total super, aber das ist halt eher die Ausnahme.
So, ich möchte noch mal zu meiner Frage von vorhin zurückkehren. Ich möchte sie mal ganz konkret stellen. Wer von euch hat schon mal einen Trojaner gekauft für die Arbeit?
Ich.
Warum?
Na, wir machen halt sich halt Mobiltelefone und da gehört unter anderem dazu, dass wir auch gucken, wie funktionieren so eine Trojaner. Wenn man halt sich so einen Trojaner auf dem Telefon einfängt, haben wir Möglichkeiten dafür zu sorgen, dass zumindest die sicheren Telefonate an dem Trojaner vorbeigehen. Wie kann man erkennen, dass ein Trojaner auf dem Telefon drauf ist anhand von verschiedensten Parametern? Und dazu gucken wir uns die natürlich an. Also ganz normaler Arbeitsprozesse gucken wir uns jetzt nicht alle an, aber so die up-to-date zu bleiben, was so die wesentlichen Tricks angeht, tun wir das natürlich schon.
Also genau. Würde ich auch nicht fragen, du hast schon mal einen Trojaner gekauft?
Ich würde die lieber cracken und nicht kaufen.
Aber du hast mal einen Trojaner besorgt? Selbstverständlich natürlich.
Ich hab mir auch schon mal einen Trojaner besorgt. Aber ich bau dann eher mal irgendwie sowas selber, wenn das notwendig ist für solche Sachen.
Wir haben regelmäßig Kunden, die sich welche einkaufen.
Okay, so, jetzt hab ich gehört, dass neulich den Besitz eines Trojaners einer Staatsanwaltschaft ausgereicht hat, um Rechner aus diversen Häusern zu tragen. Frank, du hast das jetzt schon gelaufen.
Genau, also die haben, ich glaube, was war die letzte Zahl? Ich muss noch mal auf Heise gucken, was die... Also ein gutes Dutzend Hausdurchsuchungen durchgeführt um...
13.
Ja, 13, ja. Bei Leuten, wo sie irgendwo hier die Information hatten, dass die einen Android-Trojaner gekauft haben.
Okay, was war der Hintergrund dieses Android-Trojaners?
Paragraph 202c StGB.
Nee, ich meine nicht den russischen Hintergrund, sondern diese Android-Trojaner. Was zu sagen, was ist das für ein Ding?
Also, vielleicht nochmal kurz. Was ist ein Trojaner? Trojaner ist eine Schadsoftware, die auf irgendeinem Gerät läuft und in der Regel halt einen Fernzugriff ermöglicht. Dieser Trojaner muss, um das zu tun, in der Regel mit einem zweiten Rechner sprechen. Nennt man in der Regel Command & Control Server. Das heißt, das ist der Rechner, dem der Trojaner meldet, guck mal hier. Hier wurde gerade eine E-Mail geschrieben. Die hab ich mal abgezweigt. Oder hier ist gerade ein SMS eingegangen. Oder wie du mir befohlen hast, habe ich mal ein Foto gemacht und schicke das zurück. Und wenn man sowas dann irgendwann mal gebaut hat, dann könnte man entweder den Leuten das alles Open Source zur Verfügung stellen und sagen, hier habt ihr einen schönen Demo, Trojaner. Oder man könnte auf die Idee kommen, zu sagen, okay, ich mach daraus ein Geschäftsmodell, dass ich diese App an Menschen verkaufe, die die dann auf natürlich nur ihrem eigenen Telefon zu Testzwecken installieren und mir monatlich einen Betrag dafür bezahlen, dass sie auf meinen Command-and-Control-Server zugreifen können, mit dem ich ja dann die infizierten Geräte ausspioniere und ich ihnen dann Zugriff auf diese Daten gebe.
Die typische Argumentation dazu ist, dass sie sagen, man passt auf seine Kinder auf oder sowas. Das sind halt so die klassischen, du willst ja nur Gutes für diese Menschen tun, die du dann mit diesem Trojaner infizierst. Natürlich ein ultradreckiges Geschäftsmodell, was irgendwie auch in keiner Weise zu unterstützen ist. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich so, dass jetzt alleine aus dem Besitz eines solchen Trojaners zu folgern, dass es ein böser Mensch ist, ist dann halt schon eher schwierig.
Aber das ist ja genau das, was hier passiert ist. Die haben irgendwie mitgekriegt, der hat jemanden Trojaner gekauft und die sind erstmal dran.
Sagt man. Also das ist ja nun auch noch nicht so richtig klar, was da genau zu den Hausdurchsuchungen geführt hat. Es gibt halt einen Betroffenen oder einen angeblich Betroffenen, der sich in einem Forum zu Wort gemeldet hat und gesagt hat, hier bei mir war so eine Hausdurchsuchung, gibt es da noch mehr Betroffene von. Und ich habe das halt keineswegs für irgendwelche kriminelle Zwecke gekauft. Und die scheinen halt offenbar über irgendwelche Paypal-Abrechnungen auf ihn gestoßen zu sein. Was halt allerdings überhaupt nicht klar ist, ob das ein Fake ist, ob das irgendwie wirklich so ist, dass dieser Mensch sich da in diesem Forum auf die Art und Weise zu Wort gemeldet hat. Und es kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft tatsächlich, weiß ich, 100 Fälle hatte und tatsächlich nur 13 rausgepickt hat. Man weiß es halt einfach nicht. Und wenn es allerdings so ist, wie da so beschrieben wurde, dann haben die halt angeblich eben anhand dieser Paypal-Abrechnungen eine Hausturchsuchung durchgeführt auf dieser Basis.
Und jetzt zum juristischen Hintergrund. Was ist dieser Paragraph 202 C?
Das ist der sogenannte Hacker Tool Paragraph. Also das ist halt ein Paragraph, der eingeführt wurde als Strafgesetzbuch. Eigentlich ursprünglich als ein oder anderen Nachschlagparagraph. Also wenn du halt irgendwie eine Computerkriminalitätshandlung begehst und du benutzt dabei oder besitzt zu diesem Zweck halt spezialisierte Hacker Tools, dann gibt es noch mal zwei, drei Jahre oben drauf. So war halt die Intention dieses Paragraphen. Wir haben versucht, gegen ihn vorzugehen. Auch beim Bundesverfassungsgericht. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber abgelehnt, diesen Paragraphen zu kassieren mit der Begründung, dass er eben nur zum Zuge kommt, wenn eine kriminelle Intention vorliege. Die Idee war zu sagen, wir können jetzt nicht differenzieren, ob du dieses Tool besitzt, um Sicherheitsforschung zu betreiben oder irgendwie andere Leute anzugreifen. Deswegen soll er nur zur Anwendung kommen, so die Begründung in der Ablehnung des Verfassungsgerichts. Wenn klar ist, dass es eine kriminelle Intention vorliegt.
Also du musst erst mal beweisen, dass du nicht kriminell bist. Die Beweislastung wird umgekehrt und alle haben Spaß.
Langsam, langsam. Die Idee war, wenn wir nachweisen können, dass du kriminell aktiv bist und du diese Tools hast, dann bist du dran. Praktisch ist es aber so, wenn du so ein Ding hast, bist du verdächtig.
Ganz am Anfang war es so, dass die Ursprungsintention des Gesetzgebers aus dieser Cybercrime-Konvention kommt. Die wollten ursprünglich eigentlich all diese Tools illegalisieren. Dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass sie damit quasi die gesamte Security-Forschung ein bisschen illegalisieren und haben sich dann umgeschwenkt in der Begründung dieses Paragrafen zu sagen, wir wollen es nur, wenn eine kriminelle Intention vorliegt. Dementsprechend wurde dieser Paragraf extrem selten angewandt. Also ich glaube, seit seiner Einführung nur so ein paar Dutzend Mal oder so, ist ein sehr seltenes Delikt in der Kriminalstatistik. Und deswegen ist dieser Fall jetzt eben auch so bemerkenswert, weil es so einer der ersten Anwendungen wäre, wo man sagt, okay, der reine Besitz dieses Tools ohne Beweis einer kriminellen Intention dabei wird schon als Grundlage für Ermittlungen, Hausdurchsuchungen und so weiter und so fort benutzten. Deswegen ist dieser Fall heute auch so wichtig, weil wie gesagt, bisher war es größtenteils, bis auf sehr, sehr wenige Ausnahmen so, dass der erste Anwendung kam, wenn klar war, okay, da gibt es sowieso einen Computerkriminalitätsfall. Und dann suchen wir nochmal ein paar Grapfen, damit wir nochmal zwei Jahre mehr drauf packen können.
Aber ist das so, dass du gerade meintest, du musst jetzt eigentlich selber beweisen, dass du nicht kriminell bist?
Das wäre jetzt die Folge davon, wenn diese Hausdurchsuchungen und so weiter, die jetzt da gerade passieren, dann wäre es halt eine Änderung in der Interpretation dieses Paragrafen. Das ist halt das, was wir damals auch beklagt haben, was wir gesagt haben, so wie der Paragraf da im Gesetzbuch steht, lädt er dazu ein zu wügwürdiger Strafverfolgung. Weil er sozusagen so wie er im Gesetz steht, wenn du ihn buchstabengetreu interpretierst, reicht der reine Besitz eines Werkzeugs. Und nur in der Begründung des Gesetzes, auf die sich dann das Verfassungsgericht bezogen hat, steht halt drin, gemeint ist aber nur, wenn du halt eine kriminelle Intention hast.
Aber wie ist es denn für euch dann als Sicherheitsforscher, die ja alle ja böse Trojaner gekauft haben, wie ich gerade von euch erfahren habe, wollt ihr dann so eine Art Waffenschein einführen? So hier, ich bin berechtigt, ein Trojaner?
Das ist natürlich völliger Quatsch. Diese Diskussion gab es halt damals. Das kommt auch immer wieder hoch zu sagen, lizenzierte Sicherheitsforscher, so dieser ganze Kram. De facto wäre das eine massive Einschränkung der Handlungs- und Berufsfreiheit, die sicherlich verfassungsmäßig keinen Bestand hätte.
Das würde ja völlig verhindern, dass man so Sicherheit lernt, wie ihr das alle gemacht habt.
Genau, man kann sich da nicht als freischaffender Sicherheitsforscher reinbringen. Zumal es dann natürlich weitergeht. Weil dir so, wie dieser Paragraf da halt steht, ist ja auch für Umgehungswerkzeuge zum Beispiel zu benutzen. Umgehungswerkzeuge können so etwas wie Reverse Engineering Tools sein. Also Tools, mit denen man halt dekompilieren kann. Also das ist halt so...
Als eine Auslegungssache.
Genau, wie man es... Also man kann ihn, wenn man ihn bösartig auslegt, ist dieser Paragraf geeignet, irgendwie alles, was sich außerhalb der Anwendung von normalen, diesen Agreements, die man anklicken muss, wenn man so Software kauft, wie bewegt, zu illegalisieren, wenn man es halt ernst nimmt.
Okay, deine Frage auch zum Publikum?
Na aktuell wäre es dann ja auch der LYNX Text Browser, der kein JavaScript ausführt. Und deswegen den Ad-Blocker-Blocker nicht macht. Das wäre dann auch ein Tool zum Umgehen von Sicherheitsstunden.
In dem Fall ist das Urheberrecht dann eine Umgehung von digitalen Wörtern.
Das 202 ist immer nur Ausspähen von Daten und Veränderungen von Daten.
Also beziehst du dich jetzt gut mit der Chemologie.
Das, worauf du dich gerade beziehst, ist umgehen einer wirksamen Schutzmaßnahme.
Aber die Logik ist dieselbe.
Genau, die Logik ist dieselbe. Wenn ich Tools habe, die dann z.B. JavaScript nicht ausführen und deswegen der Passwortdialog nicht funktioniert auf einer Webseite, was ein völlig bescheuertes und unruhigermaßen Schutz wäre. Aber ich habe Tools, die sich nicht an das halten, was so normal ist. Und sind das dann plötzlich Hacker-Tools, die darunter fallen?
Also wie gesagt, muss man unterscheiden, was die gesetzliche Logik angeht, Umgebungstools versus Hacker-Tools. Aber klar ist halt, dass diese Logik zu versuchen, den IT-Nutzer auf allgemein konforme, vom Hersteller intendierte Nutzung zu beschränken, steckt natürlich dahinter. Also zu sagen, wer macht denn schon sowas? Das können doch bloß böse sein. Du kannst doch bloß eine böse Intention haben, wenn du solche Werkzeuge besitzt. Es ist halt so, wie wenn sie dich auf der Straße anhalten, und du hast Lockpicking-Tools dabei. So deren Idee davon. Und denen dann zu erklären, die Hälfte meiner Freunde hat Lockpicking-Tools dabei, weil es halt praktisch ist, wenn man wieder vor einer verschlossenen Tür steht. Diese Logik verstehen die halt sehr schwer.
Gibt es denn jetzt irgendwie den Willen, vom Clubhouse noch mal politisch was gegenzumachen? Oder die sitzt man jetzt erstmal abwarten und guckt?
Der Punkt ist halt, dieser 202C ist uns schon lange natürlich ein Dorn am Auge, weil er hängt halt wie so ein Damoklesschwert über halt dem, ja, allem, was wir so tun und machen. Deswegen sind wir damals halt auch vor das Fastensgericht gezogen und haben halt versucht, das irgendwie da abzubiegen. Mittlerweile ist es halt schwieriger geworden, das zu ändern. So, weil halt natürlich Zeit ins Land gestrichen ist und man halt jetzt eine völlig neue Argumentation braucht. Allerdings ist es halt so, dass natürlich, insbesondere halt in diesem Computerstrafrecht, da gibt es halt relativ häufig Novellen der Gesetze. Also da gibt es halt irgendwie so alle drei, vier Jahre, fassen sie das wieder an, um es halt irgendwie an die aktuelle Zeit anzupassen und jeweils dann gibt es halt eine Chance, da halt auch Sachen zu kippen. Und klar ist halt auch, dass der, also das insbesondere jetzt der Weg ist, halt Grundsatzurteile zu erstreiten, die halt sicherstellen, dass die Interpretation dieses Paragrafen halt eben nicht, also der Abverwandteil...
Aber heißt das mal, müsste ich jetzt so sagen, juristisch gegen diese Durchsuchung vorgehen?
Ich denke, das wird sich dann wohl darauf hinaus bewegen. Ja, also mindestens irgendwie, wenn es denn da zum Verfahren kommt, gegen Durchsuchung alleine vorzugehen, ist meistens schwierig. Aber mindestens wenn es da halt ein Verfahren gibt, dann muss man halt dein Grundsatzurteil einstreben.
Problematisch wird es halt vor allen Dingen dann, wenn halt so eine Durchsuchung erst mal stattfindet, bei jemandem, der das tatsächlich eben aus Forschungszwecken gekauft oder erworben hat und vielleicht sogar auch irgendwie bei sich benutzt. Die Person oder eben der Sicherheitsforscher oder diese Sicherheitsfirma, die muss sich dann erst mal mit dem ganzen Prozedere einer Hausdurchsuchung auseinandersetzen. Da werden wahrscheinlich Arbeitsgeräte beschlagnahmt. Und auch wenn am Ende die Staatsanwaltschaft die nicht mehr ermittelt und die Anzeige zurücknimmt und so weiter, dieser Stress bleibt und auch irgendwie dieses ganze Risiko, was dann damit verbunden ist, wenn die Rechner erst mal einkassiert wurden.
Also das weiß man wahrscheinlich, wenn eine Hausdurchsuchung, wenn die Rechner bestarkt werden, kann das Jahre dauern, bis man die wiederbekommt. Also die sind dann quasi praktisch, sind die erst mal weg. Und dann kann man das vielleicht einmal nochmal neu kaufen. Aber spielst du es beim zweiten Mal, wird es dann irgendwie haarig.
Also du musst deinem Anwalt mehr bezahlen, um dir die Kisten wieder zu bringen als neue Rechner kosten.
Also das Wertproblem ist ja gar nicht so das Problem, sondern mehr, dass du eben arbeitsunfähig bist und dadurch einen ganz anderen Verlust hast und eben auch deine Kunden nicht bedienen kannst usw. Also das ist schon ziemlich übel. Macht Backup von eurer Hardware.
Die nehmen sie ja auch nicht.
Macht Offside-Bags ab.
Macht verschlüsselte Offside-Bags ab.
Genau. Das Grundübel von diesen Paragrafen 202c ist, dass man davon ausgeht, dass Software überhaupt so einen intendierten Anwendungszweck hat und dass sich dadurch irgendwie die Vorbereitung des Ausspähens von Daten überhaupt manifestieren könnte. Ein Tool, was wir alle die ganze Zeit nutzen, ist zum Beispiel Wireshark, was Netzwerktraffic sichtbar macht. Auch den von anderen Netzwerkteilnehmern unter gewissen Umständen. Und da wird jeder, der in irgendeinem Netzwerk auch nur arbeitet oder Tests macht, da muss man nicht mal was mit Security zu tun haben, arbeitet die ganze Zeit mit diesem Tool. Das ist aber natürlich auch das Tool, was ich benutze, wenn ich irgendwie im Hotel 20 Euro fürs WLAN bezahlen soll und das aber nicht bereit bin zu zahlen. Das heißt, da begehe ich dann vielleicht eine Straftat oder mache irgendwas falsch. Jetzt könnte man den Wireshark Leuten sagen, die sind mitschuldig, weil sie mir dieses Tool zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Diese Geräte, diese Tools haben eben immer wieder andere Anwendungsmöglichkeiten und es lässt sich auch nicht von vornherein sagen, dass egal, welche Software du jemandem gibst, nur für diesen Zweck einsetzbar ist. Also ich kann mit Microsoft Word erpresser Briefe schreiben. Deswegen ist Microsoft nicht schuld daran. Also so weit gehen bei Basis-Tools die Anwendungszwecke tatsächlich auseinander. Und deswegen natürlich würden wir uns alle vorstellen, dass es irgendwie sinnvoll wäre, kriminelle Anwendungen von solchen Tools zu verbieten und gleichzeitig die Tools schön in schwarz und weiß zu teilen. Und das geht eben nicht, weil es einen riesigen Graubereich gibt, wie du bestimmte Tools anwenden kannst. Und natürlich kannst du Metasploit nehmen und dir irgendwie einen Basic-Trojaner zusammenschustern und den irgendwie deiner Freundin auf ihren Windows-Rechner schieben. Kannste machen, geht.
Sollte aber nicht.
Sollte nicht. Und das Wichtige ist, da die Grenze zu ziehen, wo du es machst und nicht da die Grenze zu ziehen, wo du dir Metasploit runterlädst oder einen Trojaner baust und dir Wissen darüber aneignest oder Metasploit der Menschheit zur Verfügung stellt.
Man kommt natürlich trotzdem zu den Feinheiten, also diese Leute, die diese Android-Trojaner über die wir gesprochen haben, da will man ja eigentlich schon unterstellen, die verkaufen jetzt nicht aus guten, also nicht nur an Sicherheitsvorschriften, die verkaufen das ja, also die machen daraus ein Verkaufsmodell, weil halt tatsächlich Leute das irgendwie ihrem Freund Freundin aufs Handy spielen wollen. Was macht man mit denen?
Ich sage mal so, ich wehre jetzt nicht dagegen Leuten, die Werkzeuge, die explizit mit dem Ziel vermarktet werden, andere Leute auszuspionieren, denen halt auf den Pelz zu rücken, auch heuristisch. Also egal, ob sie die jetzt exportieren in irgendwelche Regime oder ob sie die halt so bewerben nach dem Motto hier, kannst du deine Freunde ausspionieren, in dem Augenblick ist deren Intention ja klar. Also in dem Augenblick ist ja klar, was sie eigentlich wollen. Ist jetzt was anderes als ein Sicherheitsforscher, der halt irgendwie einen Export schreibt und den publiziert oder auch einen Hersteller verkauft. Wenn man hingeht und sagt, ok, hier ist ein Werkzeug und dieses Werkzeug ist geschrieben, beworben, intendiert, im Handbuch dokumentiert als Werkzeug für Spionage. Ja Gott, also da hab ich jetzt überhaupt nichts dagegen, wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft denen auf den Pelz rückt. Also dem Verkäufer.
Ja, aber nicht den Leuten, die das kaufen. Das sagt lange nichts über die kriminelle Energie der Käufer aus.
Correct.
Ok, jetzt haben wir viel gelernt über das Security-Business. Ich würde jetzt noch so gerne eine kleine Abschlussrunde machen wollen und das würde noch mal zu den Anfängen zurückkommen wollen. Und von jedem von euch noch mal fragen wollen. Wenn man sich jetzt in die Sendung gehört und denkt so, ok, das ist nicht ganz so glamourös und ich darf tatsächlich nicht immer eine schwarze Skimasket tragen, aber ich interessiere mich vielleicht trotzdem dafür. Aber Hoodie. Ich interessiere mich vielleicht trotzdem dafür. Wo fängt man am besten wie an? Was liest man? Was würdet ihr empfehlen? Wie steigt man da rein? Naja, sag mal ein konkretes Beispiel. Was soll man sich mal angucken?
Standards lesen. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, man möchte das IT-System auf Sicherheit überprüfen, hilft es halt ungemein, die RFCs zu lesen und sich an den RFCs zu orientieren, um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie Sachen aufgebaut sein sollen, wie sie spezifiziert sind und dann halt dementsprechend auch danach prüfen.
Also ich würde tatsächlich eher Exploits lesen.
Du hast eine andere Herangehensweise, ja.
Tatsächlich eher sagen, okay, also die weniger masochistische. Genau, also davon lernen, wie andere Leute das Thema kaputt gemacht haben. Aber es gibt ja halt die...
Wie kommt man da gefahrfrei eigentlich rein?
Also es gibt einen sehr einfachen Weg. Es gibt halt die sogenannten CVEs, das sind halt irgendwie die veröffentlichten Fehler im System. Und die beschreiben zumindest erstmal grob, wie dieser Fehler funktioniert. Also was ist ich irgendwie? Unchecked Memory oder sonst irgendwas. Was halt immer diese Art und Weise ist, wie dieser Fehler auszunutzen ist. Und in vielen Fällen ist es dann halt eben so, dass man zum Beispiel zu so was wie Metasploit gehen kann, wo dann halt zu diesen High-Level Beschreibungen, wie dieser Fehler zustande kam und wie er auszunutzen ist, eben auch das Source Code zu finden ist. Also dann kannst du einfach gehen und ein Metasploit-Modul dazu laden, dir den Source Code angucken, das mal ausprobieren, mal die Situation nachstellen, mal gucken, wie es funktioniert. Und davon halt lernen. Also danach einfach lernen. Viel ist halt eben die Erfahrung zu bauen oder aufzubauen, wie solche Sachen typischerweise kaputt gehen, wie sie typischerweise ausgenutzt werden. Ganz viele Sachen sind halt heutzutage auch Kombinations-Exploits. Also wenn du halt irgendwie diese Technik, diese Technik und diese Technik kombinierst, kommst du auch um diese Sicherheitsmaßnahmen drum rum. Oder unter diesen unwahrscheinlichen Umständen schaffst du es halt trotzdem so.
Also ich muss nochmal, ich will die Frage nochmal im Detail stellen, weil ich stelle mir vor, wenn ich jetzt sage, mich als interessierter totaler neuer Anfänger irgendwie als Internet-Wergeber und Google hier Seite zu Seite exploits, dann komme ich sehr schnell auf irgendwie shady Dinge. Dieses Metasploit ist sozusagen auch so dieser Werkzeugkasten halt, den man sich gefahrlos angucken kann, also ohne zu sagen, gleich, okay, sehr gut.
Also ich würde vielleicht sogar, also ich würde mir noch einen einfacheren Einstieg suchen und mich den Paralympics der IT-Security zuwenden, wie sie von Mario Heiderich immer genannt werden, nämlich den Web-Security-Sachen. Weil man da relativ einfache Sprachen hat, relativ einfache Angriffsmöglichkeiten und sich einfach mal so ein altes WordPress runterzuladen und zu schauen, wie krieg ich da jetzt eine SQL-Injection hin. Das ist ziemlich abgedroschen, aber das zeigt einem eigentlich relativ viel darüber, wo Systeme, quasi in dem Fall eine Datenbank und ein PHP-Skript, wie die miteinander interagieren und vor allem immer wieder darauf zurückzukommen, dass man natürlich immer Systeme da hackt, wo sie Input entgegennehmen. Und sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, wie verarbeitet dieses System mein Input und was ist Input, was dieses System nicht erwartet. Erwartet ist irgendwie vielleicht nicht so großen Input oder erwartet ist, wenn ich hinschreibe, der Input ist klein und ich gebe ihm aber großen, kommt es damit zurecht. Also sich einfach so zu überlegen, welches nicht erwartete Input kann ich dem System geben, was es im Zweifelsfall aus dem Tritt bringt. Und so eine SQL-Injection ist da immer noch relativ einfach umzusetzen. Und da lernt man glaube ich am ehesten auch einerseits, wie einfach sowas teilweise funktionieren kann und wie schwierig es ist, sowas zu verhindern.
Noch eine Frage aus dem Publikum.
Eine Ergänzung, es gibt auch wunderbare Webseiten im Netz, wo man sich so durchklicken kann und so Sachen ausprobieren kann, die dafür gemacht sind. Das sind dann so Online-Kurse, also nicht jetzt auf irgendeine Webseite losgehen, da kann man Ärger kriegen. Und ansonsten gibt es Capture the Flag-Wettbewerbe, wenn man da irgendwie mitmachen möchte. Es gibt oft irgendwo lokale Gruppen, die an sowas teilnehmen. Da kann man auch einfach mal hingehen und sich das angucken. Vorher mit den Leuten reden, die freuen sich meistens über Besuch. Haben wir auch in Berlin an der TU zum Beispiel so eine Gruppe, die relativ gefährlich ist. Und ansonsten halt diese Webseiten, die erklären das auch. Und da kann man so einen kleinen Contest machen und sich da durcharbeiten.
Oder selber was bauen, ans Internet hängen und gucken, wie es aufgemacht wurde.
Dann gucken, dass du nicht plötzlich Trittbett wirst. Da musst du wirklich gucken, dass das dann nicht so, wenn du das Wochenende weg bist, plötzlich dann den Server komplett killt oder so.
Okay, jetzt würde ich gerne sagen, diese Webseiten, die du gerade erwähnt hast, wo man sie hinkriegen kann, das wäre schön, wenn du die in die Shownotes eintragen könntest, damit der geneigte Hörer das auch vielleicht nachschlagen kann. THS, hast du noch berühmte letzte Worte?
Nö, ich finde die Sache mit den Webseiten, das ist halt durchaus eine Sache, wo man einen guten Einstieg finden kann. Und was vor allen Dingen auch der echten Welt entspricht und nicht ganz so theoretisch ist. Aber das mit den CTF-Challenges wollte ich auch anbringen, weil es gibt halt A, Gruppen, die sich treffen und das so trainieren. Und halt auch irgendwie Neuankömmlinge erzählen, was sie da machen können. Und es gibt halt die Challenges von den Wettbewerben und so weiter auch noch zum Runterladen im Netz. Das heißt, man bekommt halt Programme und irgendwelche Dinge, die man halt tatsächlich auch hacken kann. Also das ist halt natürlich Teil dieser Challenge, dass man sie auch irgendwie hacken und knacken kann. Und in der Regel decken diese Challenges ja schon einen großen Teil der Real-World-Beispiele so ab. Also von daher ist das kein so schlechter Einstieg. Ich persönlich würde halt den Leuten aber auch dazu raten, wenn ihr euch wirklich damit auseinandersetzen wollt, was halt auch neu ist, dann schaut euch halt auch einfach mal was Neues an und versucht das von vorneherein zu verstehen. Also ich meine, wo es halt irgendwie Low-Hanging-Fruits gibt, ist halt tatsächlich in diesem Internet-of-Things-Bereich. Geht einfach mal irgendwo hin und kauft euch vier WLAN-Steckdosen und schaut einfach mal, was da drin steckt, ob man da Daten auslesen kann. Und so kann man halt auch Stück für Stück teilweise neue Sachen lernen. Und wenn ihr zum ersten Mal den Lötkolben in die Hand nehmt und irgendein Arduino an irgendein Speicherchip anlötet, dann ist das halt auch schon mal ein echter Gewinn für diese. Man sieht halt auch, dass da was passiert, dass da halt ein Lerneffekt einsetzt und so weiter. Von daher kann ich das eigentlich nur empfehlen, sich nicht immer nur auf die Sachen zu konzentrieren, die andere schon bewiesen haben, dass sie machbar sind, sondern halt auch wirklich einfach den Mut zu haben und zu sagen, ich setz mich jetzt einfach mal hier ran und beiß mich da halt ein paar Wochen durch. Und dann kommt man da auch zu einem Ergebnis.
Okay, und jetzt hab ich noch eine allerallerletzte Frage mit einer Bitte um kurze Antwort an meine vier Gäste. Und das ist, Frank hat es schon gesagt, eine Orchideensfürchter ist, wenn irgendein Alter tief immer zu lange in dem Beruf ist. Was würdet ihr machen, wenn ihr nicht mehr in der Security-Branche arbeitet, Frank? Tatsächlich Orchideen?
Tja, ich glaube, ich würde irgendwas machen, was mehr mit Atomen als mit Bits zu tun hat, so ganz Porsche, also mehr so Dinge, die mit physischer Hardware, also vielleicht Roboter oder sowas.
Also ich habe ja so eine Zeit hinter mir, wo ich mich mal von den Computern gelöst habe und den Menschen zugewandt habe. Und als ich dann mit dem Psychologiestudium fertig war, habe ich mir dann auch echt wieder gedacht, vielleicht doch lieber Computer.
Wir gehen dann noch mal zusammen studieren und machen ein Diplom Holzwirt.
Alles klar.
Holzwirt ist doch eine super Sache.
Sehr schön, also doch euch Ideen und Holz. Wunderbar, das war die Sendung Chaosradio 2017 über professionelle Hacker. Wir ziehen uns jetzt alle wieder unsere Skimützen auf. Vielen Dank an Frank, Linus, Sebas und TAS, die Gäste waren. Vielen Dank an Peter, der sich das Thema ausgedacht hat. Vielen Dank an Dalimo, der einen Großteil der Orga gemacht hat und viel fluchen musste. Vielen Dank an Mutags, der Kamerakind war und viele Fragen gestellt hat. Und Wettervogel, der den Sound so geregelt hat, dass ihr uns auch alle hören konntet. Ihr könnt diese Sendung runtergeladen haben unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Ihr könnt auch Fragen oder Vorschläge, Themenvorstellungen geschicken an chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und alles, was mir jetzt noch zu sagen bleibt, ist, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Offside-Backups.
Tschüss!
How much weed they drink.